*Beeps and boops*
*smash bros theme*
*punch sound effect*
*clap x2*
Huh, look at this. Look at this cute lil' meme.
I bet he was thinking, "Why..? I'm still alive?!
Why has he not reviewed me yet?
Maybe I get to live!
It's a miracle!
NO!
That's enough!
Satanic Pewds: I HAD ENOUGH OF THIS MEME
It's a cute little meme everybody.
God: Creates humans.
Humans: Creates other reli-ligerzins (Pewd speak for religions)
God: Excuse me?
What the F!
Germany: Alright, the wars going great.
*Awkward Pewd Laughter*
Don't quote me on that
Now we all have- Now we only have now we only have to worry about Russia and Great Britain.
Japan: *bombs Pearl Harbor*
EXCUSE!
What the F?!?
Entschuldigung, VTF. Pewds: Entschuldigung
Look at the solar system every single other planet has been proven round. So what cluster of event led to the earth being flat?
Riddle me that
The earth is not a planet.
Excuse me. WTF
When someone uses the wrong meme
template, oh, I don't think so
Use the right one meme correction when someone tries to take your hat
Me hat. Alright, this meme definitely deserved to die
Congratulations when you are in a crowded area, and you need to get somewhere
Excuse me, when the Lego set says eight to twelve years, but you ate it in 30 minutes. Excuse me
Why did I come back for this? I
Should have just stayed in there
When you walking through the there and expected to be crowned king, but instead 40 centers which way with daggers jump you
Excuse me
Excuse me what the duck I like that one. I like that one. Look I guess they didn't swear gonna give this me
Mikkel just like in Rick and Morty
or schmeckle
Meme update that's right a new segment everybody this lady
She said I'm ready to become a meme, oh no. Oh no, no careful
What you wish for I run away a couple days
It's been a wonderful time, but I know what everyone has wanted me to answer while I was gone. What if
What if all right listen level with me here Okay? What if Ben Shapiro..
was fortnite.
Ben where we at
*robotic voice* Fortnite
Every single day. I watch this video feel free to bookmark this video so you can come back to this segment as well
I've got an important announcement to make meme announcement
All right. Listen up kids. This is very very important. Are you writing this down? All right
Let's do this *burp* on August 6. Let's all
Go to McDonald's and ask for the fortnight burger
The the look on the workers face will be awesome
Are you with me? Okay. All right. How about this on August 8th? Let's all go to Taco Bell
Then look on the workers face will be awesome
All right, okay. All right, okay. All right, okay
How about this on August 6 like so go to McDonald's and ask for all the money in the cash register?
The look on the workers face will be awesome. Oh
Okay, all right, okay, okay, what about this all right on August 31st
We all will visit a nightclub. Mm-hmm and ask to be let in. Mm-hmm. We won't pay in vbucks.
I got so much v bucks
I'll be the king of the dance floor. Okay. All right. How about this? All right listen up
All right, you're you're tough guy to convince I get it. Okay. All right
All right, if we all work together, it will work on June 4th 1989
let's all go to the Tainan man square and
Question the legitimacy of the Chinese government the look of the Communist Party face will be awesome
Come on, guys. It'll be epic. Come on guys. Okay. All right. Okay. All right, but what about this on September 11?
2009-no nope
We're not doing that. Welcome to Mcdonald's. How can I help you?
Fortnite burger
W-what
The look on your face. It's awesome. It's awesome
It's awesome. Everything is awesome
Fortnite burger
Hey Fortnite burger
FORT-nite
BURGE-
*explosion*
*"Watch Me (Whip/Nae Nae)" song plays*
FORT-nite burger
Everybody let's all work together and we can make the face on people awesome make the world a nicer place
It's nice to finally have a meme
that just cares about
Positivity this meme gets a five extra plus for positivity and a positive movement. I love positivity
It just makes me so positive. Damn. There's a monster under my beard. Yeah
Well, yes, technically there is a monster under your bed, but there's no reason to be afraid of it. Have you read the ingredients?
What Nani Nani?
Deskah Nani the F. What is this?
This is not epic  Dad there's a loser under my beard
Okay, this is epic
Okay, this is epic style. What do you see under my bad brain?
Nothing, bro. That's my world without you, bro
*emotional piano music plays*
All right, okay, all right
*lip smack*
Meme review
*clap x2*
What happened am I even reviewing memes anymore I guess I don't bro
Yes, bro. Close your eyes bro. Okay, bro
You're a good boy, bro. I know bro
Goodbye, bro. This is so sad
Alexa can you play pewdiepie playing despacito? Alexa: I can't your video got copystrike
That's right everybody!
Apparently my cover was so good that it got claimed by 21 parties, I guess
It was just too close to the original
Thank you. Really appreciate that
I'll fight this and I'll fight it. I'll take it to court god damn it. Close your eyes bro. Okay, bro
Watcha see bro?
Nuthin bro
*whisper* That's my world without you bro
Bro
THIS IS SO SAD
ALEXA can we cast obsidian? While playing Despacito? not the regular one, the Pewdiepie one
without the copy strike condition
Thank you
You don't look so good, bro
I'm fine bro
Okay, let's go tell the world we're free bro
*whispers* We're free bro
Why did you just whisper that to me bro?
Because you are
My world bro
Broooo
Mmm
All right all memes aside
Well, maybe not and you guys probably heard Stefan Karl Stefansson uh passed away after a 3 year long battle with Cancer
Normally when someone passes away it's frowned upon to make jokes about it. All right, you can't just can't do it
but with Stefan being so active on Reddit and involved in the meme community and really
Embracing with open arms the how popular that we are number one meme became on YouTube
It was such a wonderful thing to see in all the positivity that he spread around it
I thought it was a very nice thing to see how many people mean
Stefan in such a positive way after he's passing away as well
So I thought it would make sense to bring up on meme review.
It's time to go
Was I a good man?
No
I'm told you were the best
@Lushsux did an uh art piece for him
You either die a villain or you live long enough to see yourself become the hero
This is actually sad *sad laugh*
Stars are beautiful this evening. Yes. Do you know who else is beautiful?
No, who?
Stefan Karl Stefansson
Using the old format with Drake in it
Using the new improved format with Stefan Karl Stefansson
I think we should make this the default
there's also a petition going around
I recommend you guys sign it for uh
To raise a statue of Stefan Karl Stefansson in his hometown
You can't defeat me
I know but they can
Cancer Research UK
American Cancer Society
If you guys wanna donate as well
I'm gonna leave some link in the description. I'm gonna leave a link in the description as well
and also of course
Rest in Peace Stefan
That's it for me for now meme review
*clap x2*
I'll see you guys tomorrow
Good to be back
Thank you
*Inception sound*
:)